all right so as some of you are aware we
are watching the Brendan Fraser mummy in
the Tom Cruise mummy back to back now
under protest here's the tongue yes a
little bit how this came about James
Rolfe just out of nowhere is just like
are you going to talk about the new
mummy movie anytime soon because I'd
like to talk about with you like I just
have more stuff to say if I have words I
was like well I mean I was doing the
Brendan Fraser what I guess we can do
this one I think I'm not gonna turn to
our review which I saw I can almost see
the nerve twitching them she said it
stayed with him like the anger towards
the movie stayed with him I think you
just want to talk about more so this is
our first reaction we just hear it's bad
and I skipped it because I don't want to
see no it looked awful all the critics
said it was awful so I just had no
reason to see it here we go it takes
place in the end Oh Oh what are we got
going on here I smell something
incredible starting here in our universe
this is gonna be like even too dark
village that's advertising dark universe
a perfect world those don't go together
England is not ancient Egypt last I
checked it's a doc universe it's
literally dark what okay
I carry tales Russell Crowe I know yes
doc you know German well there's nothing
in here but some bubble gum I'm crazy
[Laughter]
we're missing important information we
have to watch them so we know how the
dark universe get started cuz it's gonna
be huge
I feel like this movie has already have
like three false starts like shouldn't
this be where it started yeah about that
would unleash darkness itself a shitty
line unleash darkness itself
hi I'm darkness itself I realize about
as cool as you guys at me but here's
this pointy thing messin what did that
have to do with London it's like the
poor man's brendan fraiser oh shit
this just gets worse and worse this is
the mummy or black out down there on
that filming Hana by Universal movie run
away before they cast you now I just
seems to be Chris pining it whole bunch
of military technobabble delivered in an
earnest way and the pointing with the
hands sir where is it where's what the
sprint we want rewrites I know there's
bad and greedy soldiers out there and
stuff like that but I have a real pet
peeve when they try to make us soldiers
to look bad I think that just that
really gets under my fucking skin anyway
it's supposed to be the main character
well what's this's me off you let's not
forget our hero yeah no that's why the
backs of main character is what just
fucking pisses me off but they fucking
send them in wow you're just like
completely broke a number of military
laws we should have the MPS come here
and recipes now is this ending in the
hole let's send the guy we don't fucking
trust good job as cloud don't ghana d
better seen the brendan fraiser mummy
you where they're just on the boat and
they're talking you find out about i'm
so glad they don't have any of that shit
in here now that's stupid I'm talking
about how Brendan Fraser's mummy was a
better character building developing
Phil but I think you applied your
nail-polish wrong honey there's really
not a safer way to carry that way man
yeah I'm really concerned for him cuz I
know so much about him like he wanted
treasure he's an asshole soldier man
he's played by Tom Cruise that's like
just three winners hey I'm just totally
into her character she does archaeology
things Oh the commander well okay we
don't worry about him in Atlanta eat his
face come on it's not gonna scare us
movie
thank you thank you my precious that's
so what his character would do because
they set him up so well mmm
well they're really doing the American
Werewolf in London thing
no it's an American mummy in London
that'll be part of the dark universe -
thank god there's more with them because
I loved how well they worked off each
other
dead makeup - that wasn't that good dead
makeup on that guy and it would be about
mummies a lot of time makers it's just
because you have Tom Cruise doesn't make
it interesting if anything it actually
makes it less interesting you have to
make it interesting with Mission
Impossible with mummies I may take it
back I may consider the phrase Irwin a
masterpiece you're right Brendan Fraiser
mummy like it went for the gore and
stuff like that but it's like it knew it
was stupid so it's bright and colorful
and tee hee ha ha like this is like no
we're really darker we're gonna try and
scare you like oh you're not gonna be
able to do that it's the DC Universe
shitty way of doing things I know it's
dark and gritty it's important it means
something it's gonna be a deconstruction
of whatever actually means yeah it's
like they're under the false impression
that the DC Cinematic Universe is doing
really well yeah I'm a little
necrophilia no like to necrophilia all
night woman's never done this to me this
is a new experience for me
a little fight ya see some I guess it is
supposed to be a comedy yeah coz that
was legitimately funny yeah that's
pretty bad green screen you know again I
can't believe I'm calling back to this
but remember the Brendan Fraser mummy
when the other guys just has different
body parts and the mummy just went after
each of them it's like oh I get it
each one had one of those little jars
they get back to explain anything you
just got it man
hey cuz this is what I really wanted
with The Mummy zombies stopping our
mummy apparently don't get me wrong the
last film it was a cat but still seems
pretty dumb guys it's surprising what
you can't make a ferris wheel very scary
I know you're trying to play the creepy
music and everything but that's a ferris
wheel it's delightful charges the London
Eye it's magical it's not scary oh come
on Oh Oh Howard the Duck is in one of
the girls that's what he realized the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
universal dark universe are connected
it's like oh shit I'm here for paycheck
when is Jekyll dr. Henry Jekyll
did he just say dr. Hannah chuckles oh
that's why we're in London so the whole
fucking reason we're here is so we could
have a gentleman Hyde reference I am way
too sober for this yeah look he's
turning into mr. Han Oh can't wait for
that movie mmm I only believe in Jesus
really see she's like I do not pick it
you know judgin bucks welcome to a new
world of gods and monsters it's a
modular goddamn piece of shit
having Brendan Fraser who was in gods
and monsters in the last movie was a
better life than that
fucking garbage I am going to attempt to
act please don't look directly at me
oh yeah Uncle Matt I mean cruises what
no sixty-eight Oh little too many
margaritas last night I was very
indifferent in the first mummy to who I
was really rooting for but I am just
completely on board with her I'm like
you know what I just said I want her to
win I don't know much about her
motivation I just know she wants to kill
everyone in this movie and I'm okay with
that glass blowing glass flying yeah
that glass dust you know wow that was
intense and we already have enough
Brendan Fraser smiling and stating the
obvious
underwater fights yeah because those are
always great they're fast they're
exciting you can see everything grave
it's a lot of dialogue you can have
underwater it is the best dialogue so
far movie right there
Oh servants um yeah I guess you can go
you know I didn't tell me do that that's
a little weird they turned to dust but
they were still corpses like yeah I
don't know where to go
hey they'll recycle it somewhere how
does a cat watches woman kicked out
Cruz's ass all day and I really Tom
Cruise's Doug the end movie over roll
credits I'm gonna see him jekyll and
hyde eating schwarmann together the
marriage ceremony for the host Tom
Cruise weddings sucks their souls dry
yes
are we doing werewolves is that it he
knows there's good in there so he goes
back and forth that's my guess that's
also Jaclyn yeah he's mummy van Helsing
land Helsing yeah what what was that
Seiya pretty much everything has been
said about this movies right it's even
more underwhelming than I thought yeah
I'm from advance I'm blown away even the
climax was just nothing what uh
there was no climax it's like this for
each other a little bit that was it yeah
I mean it's like just nothing
who is he supposed to be we have to wait
until the next one which I'm so excited
to see him which I know is coming it's
so funny just all the notes that they're
like well this worked in the cinema
humor this worked in us in Ag universe
but they didn't for one second think why
they worked everybody else wants that
same success instantly without putting
in the same amount of time and effort or
understand that yeah more understanding
of what the hell made it work to begin
with Shane I have a newfound respect for
the Brendan Fraser mummy we thought that
movie was just like it's alright but now
it's like man maybe that was a
masterpiece maybe be like pretty Fraser
mommy's great it's sacrosanct it's
untouchable I'm like well maybe they're
after watching this yeah that's about it
see you next time bye
you